what is sound what is sound sounds with
the cross-modal version of touch in a
way and that they are these waves that
sort of move through the air and they
get in your ear and actually hit the
eardrum and they push it back and forth
and so it's vibration really so what is
music for can I sound maybe it's a way
of ordering the sort of chaotic sounds
of a door into something that involves
structure and time why do we organize
our own into music some people think
that music was there before speech and
so the original function of music was a
kind of emotional communication system
like things fall on your toe and you go
ah maybe music used to be proto speech
and I want you to tell me how it makes
you feel
how does that make me feel that makes me
feel like I'm doomed
like run out and storm the streets that
feels very comfortable to me I love that
can you hate the sound of whistling I
felt a good bad is that possible to feel
good bad I don't know I don't know what
that means you just experienced a wide
range of emotions why did all that
happen I think of in terms of like we're
living our lives up here on the surface
of the ocean where these little boats
there's more stuff that won't ever have
access to but somehow music can get down
into his deaths I don't know what that
is is it because it's major and it's
kind of at a certain scale because it
reminds me is there time my leg get
blown all those things but somehow the
combination of it just gets around your
rational defenses and it just moves you
what then having said what you just said
what is the function of music um what is
the function of music I think uh I feel
like I should have a really good answer
for this but somehow I felt so feel like
the question is wrong function maybe it
doesn't have a function words are codes
it's just an agreement
there's nothing innate about it but like
music it doesn't mean anything it just
is the thing and I'm not sure it has a
function other than the fact that it is
inevitable and it just comes out of us I
don't know if that's an avoiding the
question or if that's actually what I
think I think it's when I think we would
be doing we would just not be who we are
unless we had music so it makes us who
we are